The "whole new world" that Disney's live-action
Aladdin will take viewers to — is apparently
the uncanny valley just outside of bizarro
town.
When the House of Mouse unveiled the second
sneak peek at this year's Aladdin, Will Smith
was finally revealed as the Genie.
"I think people are gonna love it"
The extended look dropped as a surprise during
the 2019 Grammys on February 10th — and
it was only a matter of minutes before the
internet lit aflame with reactions.
People knew it was coming, but nothing could
prepare the world for what went down in the
newest Aladdin trailer.
"You really don't know who I am.
Genie, wishes, lamp, none a that ringing a
bell"
Response to the new, blue Genie has been intense,
with countless people reacting in horror,
flaming Smith's look, drawing comparisons
between his character and other blue dudes
from pop culture, and slamming the live-action
Aladdin as a waste of money.
Josh Billinson of the Independent Journal
Review wrote:
"Dammit James Cameron, no one asked for more
Avatar movies."
Kyle Buchanan of The New York Times was downright
horrified at the vision of Smith as the Genie,
tweeting:
"They premiered this image at night???
We are supposed to sleep after this???
I have never known peace."
Buchanan went on to admit that his terror
slowly turned to twisted fascination, writing:
"The Will Smith genie makes me feel the same
way I feel when a celebrity dies: Nauseous,
sad, and like I can't wait to tell everybody
about it.
Did I scream?
Yes.
Am I pacing around my house now?
Uh-huh.
But am I also filled with […] admiration?
The ALADDIN movie is batting in the big leagues
now.
There are no other movies until this one and
there may be no other movies after."
He even joked that Smith as the Genie is what
the never-shown-on-screen monsters of Netflix's
Bird Box actually look like, posting:
"Honestly the Will Smith genie feels like
a spoiler for BIRD BOX because I finally understand
what image would make them so fascinated but
also want to kill themselves.
I just stepped outside and […] how are there
not crashed cars?
How are there not people walking around in
a daze?
Have they not seen the Will Smith genie yet?
Dare I show them?"
YouTuber Jenny Nicholson shared the same kind
of guttural reaction to Smith's blue Genie,
tweeting,
"Will Smith genie is what appears in my room
when I have sleep paralysis."
Writer and comedian Mike Drucker quipped,
via Twitter,
"This looks like the last character you unlock
in a Final Fantasy game and you rarely use
him because you've already leveled up the
rest of your party."
He then offered a chuckle-worthy juxtaposition
of Smith's take on the Genie next to Arnold
Schwarzenegger's Mr. Freeze from 1997's Batman
& Robin, captioning the photo set,
"Me when mom says I can have the house to
myself vs when mom comes home early."
Other reactions to Smith's Genie include the
many comparisons made to a Smurf, David Cross'
Arrested Development character Tobias Fünke
in his Blue Man Group audition get-up, and
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson's Scorpion King
from The Mummy 2,.
"I'm afraid I just blue myself,"
Maybe you're one of the seemingly very few
people who think Smith looks great as the
Genie, or you're indifferent because…
"Genie already looked weird in the original
Aladdin.
Because he's a genie."
Or you're dismayed at the fact that your children
will probably recognize Smith's take on the
character before they ever recall Robin Williams'
OG version.
Say you're a lot smaller than my last master
either that or I’m getting bigger!
Look at me from the side, do I look different
to you?"
Either way, there's no avoiding the inevitable.
Smith's Genie will bust out of the magic lamp
in the live-action Aladdin soon enough, no
matter if you find him shining, shimmering,
and splendid — or a thing of actual nightmares.
"I was terrified of doing the genie, y'know,
after Robin Williams, y'know"
"But I found a lane that pays homage, but
it's my own thing"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.